[Music]
on this friday night
taxpayers on the hook for the former
governor general's pension
how much canadians will have to pay as
the prime minister gets picked apart
for hand-picking julie payette obviously
he made a big mistake
the first official phone call between
justin and joe
they get along well protecting a
friendship and canada's interests
anger in alberta the province's turn to
coal mining
unearthed an uproar and a game changer
in baseball
they just was not ready for a black man
to break that record
remembering home run king and hall of
famer hank aaron
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
robin gill good evening and thank you
for joining us
the prime minister is facing fallout
tonight from the resignation of governor
general
julie payet payet was accused of
creating a toxic
work environment and it resulted in an
independent review that came to a
scathing conclusion
justin trudeau hand-picked the former
astronaut for the job in 2017.
he's not expressing regret for his
decision and insist there was a proper
vetting process
but as david aiken explains the governor
general's resignation is once again
raising questions about canada's
connections
to the crown
prime minister justin trudeau offered no
apologies for how payette
was picked obviously the vetting process
that was in place
was followed and he offered no details
about how or when payet's successor will
be named
as we move forward we will reflect
carefully on the way to
best select a successor to the governor
general
but the opposition says the payette
controversy
should be laid solely at the feet of the
prime minister it comes down to
justin trudeau who was more interested
in a flashy announcement
of the governor general rather than
doing the work of making sure it was the
right selection
obviously he made a big mistake and this
is all
100 responsibility of the prime minister
himself
now if the prime minister seeks to
dissolve parliament and call an election
he'll have to ask richard vagner the
chief justice of the supreme court
and that's a situation that
constitutional experts say
is less than ideal ideally you would
want to have a vice regal representative
in there to
do that you'd want to have an actual
governor general not the administrator
doing it
simply because it keeps those functions
nice and clearly delineated
and separate as for the 57 year old
payette
she can now expect a pension of 143 000
a year plus more than a hundred thousand
dollars a year
in travel and expense allowances i think
that canadians
rightly so are concerned that given this
report
and and how horrible the workers
were treated that this doesn't say well
with people
even before this polls have shown that
60
of canadians do not believe the monarchy
should have
any formal role to play in canada's
system of government and
if there's no crown connection there's
no
governor general the payette controversy
is bound to
reignite that issue well it certainly
raises questions that are controversial
in the minds of canadians about what the
role of the monarchy is in canada
and what it's constitutional how our
constitution works
trudeau can expect to be forced to
defend the role of the crown and
his role in the payet matter when
parliament returns from its winter break
on monday
david aiken global news ottawa the prime
minister and u.s president
have wrapped up a call the first joe
biden made to a foreign leader
the two spoke about the keystone xl
pipeline the detainment of the two
canadians in china
and climate change trudeau says it was a
good call and that's important
as eric sorenson explains this is a
chance to renew the canada u.s
relationship after four tumultuous years
in the world of canada u.s diplomacy at
the highest level
the tone seldom changes but you could
sense a weight has been
lifted from this prime minister the fact
that we have so much alignment
not just me and president biden but
canadians
and president biden justin trudeau and
joe biden have common goals
to combat covet 19 cooperate on climate
change
and a personal rapport will only help
they've talked on many occasions they
get along well
and know what to expect from each other
they're also both very committed to a
return
to normal normal relationships was
always a given
some have been warmer like
jean-critician and bill clinton some
cooler trudeau's father and ronald
reagan and stephen harper and barack
obama were clearly not close
but mostly relations have been mutually
beneficial and normal well he's too fast
donald trump changed all of that
disrespectful to trudeau
and willing to smash trade relations
just not having to wake up in the
morning and wonder
whether the president united states is
going to throw a tantrum is itself
a huge improvement it won't be all
smooth sailing biden favors by american
policies
and killing the keystone xl pipeline was
deemed even by some american politicians
as a rude opening gesture
joe biden comes out of this chute and
pops
canada right in the face but it was
widely understood when biden beat trump
that keystone was probably cooked
the government of canada must impose
meaningful trade and economic sanctions
some premiers now want to play hardball
with washington
but the prime minister after four years
is looking for common ground
and common values to give opportunities
for everyone
while we build a better future i'm very
much looking forward to working with
president biden
one issue is not the whole relationship
and there are so many areas of
cooperation which canada needs to pursue
and uh biden's policy as a policy agenda
aligns much more closely not only with
the canadian governments but with most
canadians as well roland paris says it's
an encouraging sign for this country
that president biden's first call to a
foreign leader
was to canada's prime minister eric
sorenson global news
canada's political and health leaders
are reiterating a message
stay put and cancel any travel plans new
highly contagious variants of the virus
are spreading
there are now 31 cases of the uk variant
in this country
and three of the one first found in
south africa
prime minister trudeau says the
government is looking at several options
that will make it harder for people to
return to canada
a push to restrict inter-provincial
travel has hit a roadblock in one
canadian province
after mulling the possibility of banning
people from entering bc
premier john horgan says he can't
legally do it
but as abigail beeman reports not
everyone agrees
and don't book a trip for spring break
the prime minister already looking
months ahead and he says looking at
other ways to further limit canadians
ability to travel
across the country people are being told
to stay home
so if you were thinking of traveling
across the country for spring break
now's
not the time this is the big challenge
really
these new variants kelly lee researches
how travel restrictions have worked
around the globe
she believes because of new more
transmissible variants
all provinces should enact restrictions
for non-essential travel
time is of the essence travel was on the
agenda in a call between the premiers
and prime minister thursday night
people talk have been talking about it
for months and months as you know
and i think it's time we put it to bed
bc's premier john horgan was looking at
a ban but says after talking to lawyers
it's off the table
with so much traffic due to work he says
that we have less power to restrict
economic related travel than we do in
non-economic travel
and i don't agree with him when we think
about inter-provincial restrictions we
usually think about the atlantic bubble
but constitutional lawyer sujit
chaudhary says newfoundland and labrador
may have the answer
the province instituted strict rules of
its own upheld by its supreme court
i think the newfoundland judgment would
give provinces
quite a bit of comfort that a
carefully crafted set of restrictions
that was rooted in science
and that was backed up by the best
empirical evidence
and that had a sufficiently broad set
of exemptions would likely survive
constitutional scrutiny so i think
provinces would have to work a bit
harder to justify
a measure like this the canadian civil
liberties association is appealing the
newfoundland and labrador
case and important to remember all
provinces have unique
challenges due to geography and size
with some borders like bcs
making it more difficult to seal than
the atlantic
abigail beeman global news ottawa
a coven 19 outbreak at one of canada
post's busiest processing
plants is getting bigger 149 employees
at the mississauga facility have now
tested positive for the virus
in a statement canada post says public
health has confirmed
that it is able to maintain its
operations any employees who do test
positive
will leave the workplace and
self-isolate more than 4 500 people
work at the site the biden
administration enters office a year into
the u.s
pandemic the president has promised to
provide a hundred million covet 19
vaccinations in his first
100 days in office but is there enough
vaccine to accomplish that
as mike armstrong reports at least a
dozen states are reporting shortages
the road to recovery is turning out to
be slower than predicted
states that were ready with mass
vaccination programs
are only limitations just can't run them
our
only limitation as we stand here today
is supply from the federal government
the former trump administration pushed
states to expand vaccination programs to
get shots into arms
the problem has been getting the
vaccines to the states
california ohio and west virginia are
among states warning they're running out
florida is rolling back who's eligible
and new york is canceling appointments
for next week as it braces for new
strains
the new strains are frightening the uk
strain brazil strain now the south
africa strain and they're going to be
more strains
i would wager on it new jersey's
governor toured a new vaccination mega
site friday but he's had strong
criticism
of the trump administration on supply
force he says
over promising and under delivery
operation warp speed
set goals that weren't reached 20
million people were supposed to be
vaccinated by the end of december
as of thursday the cdc says only 15
million people have been vaccinated
of that less than three million have
gotten the full two doses
the first one is the economy the biden
administration says it's still getting
its sea legs and will tackle supply
but friday the president signed two
executive orders aimed at
economic relief for families small
businesses
and struggling communities police
officers firefighters first responders
nurses they're all at the risk of losing
their jobs
now even as the country struggles to
reach its goals there are calls to move
them
even higher as new strains spread it
could drive up
infection rates if more of the public
isn't vaccinated
mike armstrong global news washington
the u.s senate has approved biden's
nomination for pentagon
chief retired army general lloyd austin
is the first
black defense secretary in u.s history
biden is looking to restore stability at
the pentagon which went through six
people in that position some permanent
some temporary during the trump
administration
sleepless in small town alberta coming
up the concerns about
coal mining leaving some people anxious
the federal government is suspending the
sale of all decommissioned rcmp vehicles
the announcement comes nine months after
a gunman disguised as an rcmp officer
used an old police vehicle during a
deadly shooting rampage
in nova scotia 22 people were killed in
one of the worst massacres in canadian
history
earlier this month a 23-year-old from
nova scotia was arrested for
impersonating a police officer
while driving a former police vehicle
outfitted with lights
and decals alberta needs to diversify
given the cancellation of the keystone
xl pipeline
so the province is turning to new
investment in metallurgic coal mining
the kind used to make steel there are
rich deposits of this coal in the
southwest part of the province
an australian mining company could get
its grassy mountain project
in the crow's nest pass greenlit by the
end of this year
but it's the government's move to
quietly open the region to further
exploration last spring
that is sparking outrage heather yorks
west reports
conservationist kevin bantigam has a
little cabin in southwest alberta
it sits near the banks of the old man
river an incredibly
important source of water in a region
that's pretty dry
virtually all our water comes from the
headwaters
from the eastern slopes of the rocky
mountains the areas that
trap a lot of winter snow and get a lot
of spring rain it's why vantigam is so
concerned about the potential resurgence
of coal mining here we're directly
impacted it's in our grazing
range ranchers laura lange and john
smith say the issue has been keeping
them up at night
all i can think about is you know the
blood sweat and tears that goes into
these places
and to have it undone
and under threat is is
it's hard to fathom across the border in
bc's elk valley coal mining has been a
major industry for decades
but in the crow's nest pass there hasn't
been an active coal operation
since the 1960s several years ago an
australian mining company applied to
reopen the abandoned grassy mountain
mine
the project is now before a joint review
panel but it has support from the local
town council
it's definitely an act would be an
economic boost to our community
and and allow us to be sustainable
moving forward in the future what's
important to understand is this is one
of the first mines
of its size in in canada that's been
designed from the ground up
to to manage issues like like water
quality
rivers dale resources says the project
will use new technology to minimize the
mine's impact on the environment but the
project isn't the only source of concern
in may alberta's government rescinded a
decades-old coal policy
that had banned strip mining in
sensitive areas of the rockies
since then dozens of leases have been
handed out and at some sites
exploration is well underway they've
created a big disturbance there we've
got all sorts of eroding surfaces and
all sorts of
damage done to that mountain and there
isn't even a mining proposal yet all
they're doing is exploring it
but in the last few weeks the public
outcry has grown country music singers
like paul brant and core blund
took to social media to show their
concern several petitions have now
attracted more than 100
000 signatures and last week a group
opposed to the coal policy changes even
took the province to court
a decision is expected in the next
couple of months
heather urex west global news calgary
still ahead a review of ontario's
vaccine rollout
and where it fell short
when compared to other countries around
the world canada's kova 19 vaccination
campaign is falling behind
in december canada ranked fifth that's
when the roll-up began
but new data shows this country has
dropped to 15th
as of yesterday canada had vaccinated a
total of more than
738 000 people
ontario is preparing to launch up to 60
vaccination sites
as part of the second phase of its
campaign this spring retired general
rick hillier who leads the province's
vaccine task force told global news that
ontario will be teaming up with
pharmacies and family physicians
tonight carolyn jarvis looks at the
first phase the missteps
successes and lessons learned
every time the phone rings kristin
hunter has a pang of anxiety
that it's her father's long-term care
home calling to say his health
has taken a turn he got infected with
covet 19 unfortunately on january the
8th
and i see it as preventable given that
though that vaccine was possible to be
in his arm before he got infected while
ontario has prioritized covet 19
vaccines for long-term care residents
and employees
alongside health care workers and first
nation communities
it has fallen behind other provinces in
reaching those seniors
quickly and we only have 626 homes
we have 72 000 people we know where they
are and we've had enough vaccine to
vaccinate all of them
from december 21st one of ontario's most
critical early decisions was to place
its vaccination hubs
in 19 hospitals but with instructions
from pfizer at the outset not to move
the vaccine
most long-term care residents couldn't
reach it
there was credible concern
about moving the vaccine that if you
move it around and actually if you
defrosted it and agitated and shook it
up it would denature it
quebec by contrast elected to put half
its vaccination centers
right inside long-term care homes and by
mid-january with fewer vaccines supplied
it has given first shots to more
long-term care residents
than ontario once pfizer provided
new distribution guidelines for its
vaccine on december 18th
british columbia started moving the
vaccine into long-term care homes
days later but ontario didn't do so
until january 5th so yeah there's clear
bumps on the road there were clear
hurdles and some missteps by then
ontario's new approach was called
speed over perfection empty the freezers
and get shots into arms but speed
meant some back office staff in
hospitals were offered the shot
before frontline workers so speed over
precision is not what we were hoping to
see
and it's certainly not fair in its
latest pivot ontario is saying long-term
care homes will be its near sole focus
only for some it comes too late carolyn
jarvis global news
toronto and to learn more about
ontario's vaccine roll out its successes
and missteps to date watch the new
reality tomorrow night at seven with
donna friesen
right here on global up next remembering
the achievements of hammering hank aaron
on and off the field
the world of baseball is looking back at
the life of a true champion tonight
hank aaron a hall of famer chased down
and broke babe ruth's home run record
but it's not just how he played the game
it's how aaron stood up to racism
as mike delay reports he was a humble
hero who fought to change america
strikes aaron waiting the outfield deep
and straight away
even after his greatest professional
moment hank aaron had every reason in
the world to be angry
he'd just broken one of baseball's
hallowed records held
by an icon in babe ruth yet for many
race is what still defined him a black
man is getting a standing ovation in the
deep south
for breaking a record of an all-time
baseball idol
in the weeks leading up to that moment
he was getting 3 000 letters a day
much of it full of unvarnished hate he
read them all
forty years later when he said he didn't
think america had changed he read all
the new ones that came in too
henry aaron grew up in mobile alabama
when he was a boy the ku klux klan came
to his family home
his mother told him to hide under the
bed he looked at baseball as his way out
and while he became a star he never
achieved the same fame or enjoy the same
rewards
as white stars like joe dimaggio or
mickey mantle
but his impact was profound it made him
mentally tough it gave him an
understanding that he wasn't just
playing for henry aaron
he was literally carrying an entire race
of people on his shoulders
body break star hal johnson says he
didn't believe his father
when he said he played with aaron in the
negro leagues at a game in montreal
johnson's father said he was going to
say hi
hal a bit shy back then refused to go
hank came out of the dugout looked at my
dad
and and opened his arms my dad goes on
the field
and my sister and big hug and by the
time i got down he was
he would stop the field aaron was his
idol as he was for so many others
including canadian hall of famer
ferguson jenkins and musician lenny
kravitz
who proudly wore a hank aaron t-shirt as
a kid
hank aaron you know he was he was just
he was just a great man
regardless of his color and he wasn't a
great black man he was just a great man
for what he did hammer and hank aaron
was 86.
what a nice story and that is global
national for this friday i'm robin gill
tonight your canada is a herd of deer
taking a stroll through prince george bc
we would love to see your corner of the
country so please keep sending your
photos
to viewers at globalnational.com thank
you for watching and i'll see you back
here tomorrow
have a great night
[Music]
you